the parents of the penn state student
who died after an alleged hazing ritual
is calling for swifter justice for their
son Timothy Piazza his father Jim Piazza
said in a statement after yesterday's
pretrial questioning quote these
hearings have tried our patience he
accused defense attorneys of attempting
to justify the unjustifiable Timothy
Piazza you may recall died back in
February after a fraternity event
involving heavy drinking Jericka Duncan
is outside the courthouse in Bellefonte
Pennsylvania where the legal process
will resume again next month Jericho
good morning good morning only five of
the defense attorneys for those Penn
State students got a chance to question
the prosecution's first witness now the
other attorneys will have their chance
next month and a two-day hearing process
remember those hearings will determine
the outcome of whether or not this case
goes to trial defense attorneys
representing the Beta Theta Pi
fraternity brothers cross examined the
lead investigator in the case Tuesday
one attorney said his client wasn't in
the frat house when Timothy Piazza fell
down a flight of stairs after an alleged
hazing ritual known as the gauntlet
others argued their clients did not
force Piazza to drink our primary
concern here is the fact that this is a
case that's clearly been overcharged
Michael Engel is representing Gary de
billy-oh one of the eight fraternity
members facing the most severe charges
involuntary manslaughter and aggravated
assault while Gary may be responsible
for certain things it's not responsible
for the serious charges in this case
according to a grand jury presentment de
Billy O and at least one other
fraternity brother advocated for calling
an ambulance but we're told Piazza's
condition was typical a bid acceptance
night during the hearings the
prosecution presented incriminating text
messages sent from some of the frat
brothers one of the texts said he looked
expletive dead the boys themselves knew
what they did the text admit it right
after before he even passes away they
say it's because of hazing it's because
of the drinking we caused this we should
have called 9-1-1
CBS News legal analysts Ricky claiming
the text messages that came from
some of these young men are what we call
in the law consciousness of guilt once
you put those things in writing
ultimately those text messages are going
to come back to haunt them in his
statement Jim Piazza encouraged the
parents of those charged to come forward
with any information everything that
they have that could be helpful he also
said that his family is committed to
this legal process and that they are
doing this for their son Tim not only
just for him they said but for all of
those that come behind him as they enter
their college years
Jeff all right Joe Rica Duncan thank you